you
everyone's Jerry this is another group
of five endgame puzzles all of them are
white to play and it's up to you to
determine the best continuation in each
case of the puzzles that I've posted to
YouTube thus far this group of five as a
whole gets my vote for being the most
difficult and so give each one some time
to figure out see how you can do with
these and I believe many of them you may
find quite appealing so much so that you
may in turn be wanting to share with the
friend or a chess club member etc to see
if you can in turn stump them but
certainly it's going to be a little bit
better if you could be able to say that
you were able to get these when you
first encountered them and so with this
again first puzzle of five with white to
play go ahead pause the video see if we
can find the best continuation for white
ok the solution to this first puzzle is
Bishop to f6 of course trying to prevent
this pond from queening successfully I
should say and note that just queening
right away black wood Queen width check
and after King takes Knight we have a
situation where just having the Queen
and Bishop is not going to be enough and
so first throwing this Bishop to f6 pawn
takes Bishop only now Knight to d4 if
the pawn promotes then we're going to
have a classic fork going on the Queen
is picked off and then white wins and so
the only way to stop this King takes
Knight now we Queen and after black
Queens we have a position very
reminiscent to that final scene in
searching for Bobby Fischer a little
skewer going on here as soon as the King
moves the Queen is picked off so a nice
little setup right here the move order
is very important again take note that
this pond will be queening with check if
the knight tries to go here landing a
fork again this move comes with check
and similarly if the knight goes here we
just take the knight in fact this you
could take the night or even queen in
that particular position because taking
the knight and then playing the bishop
here well you know that this pawn does
not have to capture the bishop in this
case could actually play the e5 and then
we just have this situation going on
where it's going to turn out to be a
drop pretty much or
if let's say Bishop takes pawn we could
have not pon takes because white would
queen with check but rather just King
takes bishop and then we have this
situation going on the Queen cannot make
use of this f6 square successfully so
the solution once again Bishop f6 pawn
takes 90 for King takes Knight promote
to Queen and then follow up with this
skewer okay that's the solution to
puzzle 1 moving on to the second one
once again white to play pause the video
see if you can find the best
continuation for white ok the solution
to this one is first playing Knight to
c7 in fact backing up I phrase these
puzzles as find the best continuation
because I don't want to give away who's
the better side and so I think it's a
bit more practical you know when you're
playing your own game you're not always
able to of course see a computer
evaluation or know if you're the better
side or not well in this case the first
or in this position the first thing to
recognize is to excuse me the first
thing to recognize is that white is no
better in fact white is having to come
up with some creative stuff in this
position and it starts out with first
Knight to c7 giving Czech Bishop takes
Knight and now Queen to a6 giving check
after Bishop takes Queen we have a case
of stalemate this is the best that Y can
do and it's a very difficult one I
believe to see because in this starting
position we have three pieces that could
be moving but just after a couple of
moves none of them can move a couple of
them are just captured and this pawn
simply cannot move because the bishop is
blocking it so Knights e7 Bishop takes
Knight Queen to a6 and if the King goes
here we would just have a case where the
Queen just keeps going back and forth if
we had King a7 this too would be another
case of stalemate and so these right
here being the key moves Knight c7
Bishop takes Knight and now Queen to a6
Bishop takes Queen and we have again a
case of stalemate this is the best that
white can do so that's the solution to
puzzle 2 moving
to the third one once again white to
play pause the video see if you can find
the best continuation for white ok the
solution to this one is to start out
with c6 and if black does not capture
this pawn we're just going to have c7
and then c8 right away
well actually another thing to point out
is if Bishop to e6 check we just have
the King moving and this pawn can't
capture now because of just King takes
bishop and so really the best that maybe
black could be doing here is that after
c6 pawn takes and now the next key move
is upon the d7 which is threatening just
Bishop takes pawn with check and then
the promotion to a queen so Bishop takes
pawn is forced and now another key move
h4 the idea behind this is to not allow
this h5 pawn to advance forward allowing
this pawn to advance would mean that
this king will be able to make use of
the h5 square so h4 puts a stop to that
and in fact threatens a mate and one
with either pawn takes pawn or Bishop
takes pawn so G takes H is forced and
now we have a case of a mate and three
and there's nothing that black can do to
stop it
Bishop takes pawn this King right here
is simply stuck and white needs only to
play their king to f6 and then Bishop to
g5 and it's mate nothing can be done to
prevent it doesn't matter what black
does here let's say c5 King f6 see for
Bishop g5 and that's mate so that's the
solution to puzzle 3 moving on to the
fourth once again white to play pause
the video see if you can find the best
continuation for white ok the solution
to this one is to first start out with
just h6 forcing this night away to let's
say that ii 6 square after king c4
taking away some squares from this king
we have now the knight needing to go to
that f8 square otherwise that pawn is
going to be promoting in a couple moves
so Knight to FA prevents this pawns
advance
and now II five a very key move
threatening to just eventually chase
this night away
if this pun is allowed to become past
this night is not going to be able to
prevent a past E and H pun it's not good
enough to do both tasks and so after
this 'if I've move black captures and
now we have night c5 forcing King to a 5
B 4 check forcing King to b6 and now one
of those deflection moves Knight to d7
the king is in a position well the king
and Knight are in a position where the
knight could land a check on that d7
square deflecting the night away and
after h7 this pawn is going to
essentially turn into pac-man really
because these guys are just going to
fall very quickly in this type of an
endgame the knight is no match for a
queen and these ponds are certainly not
going to be far enough advanced to pose
any threat to white white is going to be
winning this position so a very lengthy
variation right there to see but again
that is the solution moving on to the
last one puzzle 5 once again white to
play pause the video see if you can find
the best continuation for white ok the
solution to this one is Knight to d4
which is threatening just Knight to c6
which is checkmate these guys are just
simply out of moves there's one two
three four five six pieces that can't
move this is the only piece that could
move and it needs to go to d2 so in
order to just prolong the position it
has to land a check in other words the
key move at this point is to play King
to a-1 and we do this for tempo reasons
and that's often the case when it comes
to king night and pawn end games you
have to be very cautious of the position
of your King if you go to a two we have
a case now where the knight could take
the pawn after Knight takes Knight King
to a4 and it's not so clear how
black makes progress this if the King
moves then we just have King takes
Knight and if the knight moves well we
could always just have something like b3
and then the king could just kind of
weasel out of that little box that they
were in on the a file however at this
point right here again from this initial
position 94 after this night gives check
we don't go to a2 but rather King to a1
and so the only way to once again
prolong this this position right here in
order to stop checkmate you have to just
go ahead and give check after Knight
takes pawn Knight takes Knight King to a
four this is all forced in fact this
this initial position is a checkmate in
five after this King to a four move King
a two there is once again only one move
these are all forced moves rip to a five
and now Knight to c5 landing a check
pawn takes Knight is the only move and
then what a finish
b3 mating with upon once again just a
quick recap all these are forced moves
94-92 King a one Knight takes be Knight
takes Knight King a4 King a two
rook a five-night c5 check and then b3
mate so that's all for this video as
always I hope you got something out of
it and be sure to let me know which one
of these was your favorite take care bye